all right we should now be live and
there's already a lot of questions lined
up for me to take the first question is
a meta question should we wait till the
stream starts to ask questions kind of a
funny way to begin asking a question
about asking questions that were I to
answer yes you should wait it would
already be having asked ahead of time so
we're gonna jump over that bkbk how do I
deal with friends who disparage my
choice to study philosophy sorry if the
question is too self-centered you know I
think that's that's a common thing to
happen whether it's studying it
academically you know becoming like a
philosophy major or taking philosophy
classes or studying philosophy on your
own I suppose you could you could
there's a couple things you could do one
is remind yourself that people who
disparage philosophy generally either
have no idea what philosophy is or have
only encountered it in its kind of
debased textbook crappy YouTube video
whatever it is you know terrible intro
to philosophy class forms and so you
know you can you can kind of I wouldn't
actually like say well you don't know
what philosophy is or anything like that
because that's a conversation that then
generally just turns into a big argument
but you could you could keep that in
mind and i you know i would i would also
say maybe consider how close you want to
be with these people and how much time
you want to spend with them i mean it's
one thing when your family disparages
philosophy which was the case for me i
still have you know relatives you know
i've been i've been in this business now
officially since 1990 so now we're
talking you know 30 years and i still
have little relatives who think it's
cool to come up to me at the annual
family reunion and like make jokes about
philosophy and i quit caring about that
a long time ago
in part because you really have to you
know you got to make a decision but you
know I would I would start looking for
new friends directly you don't have to
be friends with anyone in particular
there's that old saying you know you can
pick your friends but you can't pick
your family and then you know the other
third thing I would say is important is
remind yourself that whether philosophy
is worth studying or not doesn't depend
on what anyone else thinks about it it's
got a long track record you know it's
clearly been important in many brilliant
people's lives and you know you can you
can sort of take heart in the fact that
you're participating in that I would say
Nick yes are there any phenomenologist
who'd highly recommend who aren't
prominently discussed yeah I mean the
biggest one is mock Schaller there's
this genealogy of phenomenology that
gets done in continental philosophy
where it's who Cyril who like invented
it and then Heidegger came along and
maybe Marilyn T and Sartre we're doing
some cool stuff and then it was levy nos
and then Derrida and John you know John
Luke Mario and maybe you throw Michele
honoré in there and they're all worth
reading of course but they're just
that's sort of like going into a vast
field and taking one path and saying
this is the entire field right so max
Scheler was as important as his role was
as a matter of fact you notice Heidegger
talks about him in being in time I would
also say there are some early people who
are just as important in towards
phenomenology who are not calling what
they're doing phenomenology and so I
have in mind
Maurice blown down and irony Burke's own
a little bit later than him in in France
both of whom are clearly doing
phenomenological projects and then
there's Gabrielle Marcel who is doing
phenomenology as well right
very early on and the guy who actually
the first person hears the word
existentialism and in French um you know
and then there's Edith Stein she's
really well worth reading you know if
you're into literary stuff Roman in
garden although his work is really
boring and trying like what Searles
tends to be in many respects some of us
real stuff is really fun and cool but
man some of it is really tedious and in
garden seem to have managed to only
figure out the tedious path and who else
I mean there's so many others there's
this really cool phenomenologist of
religion john airing you know who i was
reading a long long time ago there's all
this cool crossover stuff between
phenomenology and other fields whether
it be Marxism or tom is you just got to
kind of dig around Hey Bruce it's good
to see you here thanks for for that goal
I'm not sure what you're adding to that
I said with that by that that's very
nice all right let me take another one
human evolution in regard to virtue
ethics can you give some normal daily
life examples of living virtuously which
philosophers but most beneficial to you
in regards to living virtuously so I
don't have a single philosopher who's
been most beneficial to me Aristotle's
important plato's important Plutarch
Cicero you know Epictetus Seneca you
know you could go down the line they all
have contributions to make even even the
Epicureans do and then we get into
Christian thinkers who are working off
of them like you know Augustine or
boethius or and some or Aquinas and then
we get into the modern age and then
there's all the contemporary virtue
ethicists who are so important as well
so I I don't I don't have a single
favorite person but you know so what
would be an example you know one of the
things I've been giving a lot of thought
to lately and I'm probably gonna try to
engage in an exchange with Massimo
Pigliucci about it he's been talking
about this quite a bit lately as well
is you know when it's okay to ban and
block people who are being jerks or
being you know a tedious or tendentious
or whatever in it or just trolling in in
conversations online and you know a lot
of people feel like well I can't block
anyone because marketplace of ideas man
and that's clearly an extreme position
and it lays you open to all sorts of
exploitation and and sort of you knows
bad behavior and then there's this sort
of like well I can do whatever I want
you know it's my social media which
there's something too and then there's
there's something in the middle some
some rational approach to it I think
that would say this kind of behavior is
dickish and it's not gonna be tolerated
and you want to do that go do it
somewhere else you're not doing it here
in in my area this stuff is you know
kind of kind of pushing the envelope but
I'll go along with it this is this is a
positive example of back and forth
discourse about controversial topics I
think that could be you know an area of
virtue ethics we could do some
exploration of that but you know another
great example I was thinking of as I was
looking at these questions when I was
just getting set up Aristotle has this
entire discussion of generosity in the
older translations it's often called
liberality but generosity is a great
example of it and then you know you
could look at like Cicero's on duties
that has a discussion of generosity and
and affection and and beneficence when
should we give to other people whether
it be money or time or attention or
things like that that falls under virtue
ethics and so I think there's lots of
daily examples of that if you think
about where we devote things on a daily
basis Lennie penny I just started
reading Nietzsche and he's pretty hard
to read I like I really like him though
do you have any tips on how to read and
interpret him and what is the best order
to read his books in
yeah so don't expect consistency out of
Nietzsche he does not have a consistent
system he deliberately introduced
contradiction at times that said there
is there is a sort of you could call it
a viewpoint that's that's quite
widespread
don't try to reduce Nietzsche down to
like a key idea from which everything
else flows that that's people have done
that but that gives you bad readings so
it's not all about the eternal
recurrence of the same or the will to
power or perspectival ism or this it's
more like a constellation with all sorts
of complicated things and the other
thing to keep in mind is Nietzsche is a
genealogical thinker so he is he's
trying to trace out origins of things
which are contingent and could have gone
differently there's no inherent Telos
within them we we produce teleological
stuff out of it but but a lot of that is
our sort of projection in his view onto
those things so like you know if you
think about the genealogy of morals on
the discussion of punishment you know
Nietzsche says there isn't one reason
for punishment there's a whole complex
of things that sort of like grew into
this this this general idea and practice
that we have and so that I think that
can be helpful to keep in mind there's
usually a lot of stuff going on within
Nietzsche I'll mention one other thing
too so a lot of people read the birth of
tragedy and there there are a lot of
readings out there where people are like
oh man this is so cool it's Apollo and
Dionysus and like order and chaos and
that's not what Nietzsche is actually
saying there's a third main approach
that that ends up subsuming both at the
Apollonian and Dionysian and that's what
he calls the Socratic and that's that
it's not supposed to be like a dichotomy
that covers everything you know
right-brain left-brain or any sort of
nonsense like that he's describing in
that what he calls three noble
approaches to the problem of life which
means that there's ignoble ones as well
going on
and each of them can be you know quite
complex and they confuse into each other
the Greek DNA in according to Nietzsche
is different than the barbarian DNA sein
so I think you want to when you're
reading him you don't want to make easy
identifications right that might be
helpful what else best order to read his
books in there really isn't the best
order I mean I I think that it couldn't
hurt to start out with the birth of
tragedy since it was his first book but
it really depends on what your what
you're looking for you know some books
are more systematic than others so
genealogy of morals and birth of tragedy
are probably the most systematic books
even they're not that systematic and
then there's all the rest right and and
I think you can I think you can read
around because you know I always say
this anyone anyone any philosopher that
you're reading expect to read and reread
and reread so it's not like you read a
book first master that then move on to
the next thing on the basis of like
having totally gotten the first one down
you're gonna come back to the first one
so if you started out by reading you
know Beyond Good and Evil that's fine
you know read it all the way through and
then maybe read it again and then you'll
you'll eventually you know read some
other works and then you'll come back to
beyond good and evil and you'll say oh
that's what was going on in this part
now now I get it right and it's the same
way if you're studying Plato or
Aristotle or Descartes or whoever I mean
with Descartes there's basically two
books that almost everybody reads and
that's the discourse and the meditations
but you know there's also some other
great stuff as well and you could read
and that would help you better
understand what's going on there
Matthew asks I'm struggling to
understand yeah Spurs encompassing are
there any good yeah Spurs scholars you
know I don't know I went to the the yeah
Spurs in the internationally aspera
Society when I was a graduate student
it was having a joint session with the
Society for phenomenological and
existential philosophy and back then I
was really interested in existentialism
and so I was like oh yeah squares that's
cool you know I'll go go check that out
and I ridged a bunch of kooks they were
like six of them and I was you know I
was the only person like under fifty in
that room and they're just talking back
and forth and it was sort of like a
Jasper's admiration society you know and
they were so happy to have some fresh
blood that Canada it was kind of a
turn-off and and I just never have
looked for people who are secondary Lit
yah Spurs you know teachers or anything
like that so I I don't really have
anything useful to contribute when it
comes to that unfortunately um TK is
there anything someone can mentally tell
themselves other than fake it til you
make it
when confronted with self-doubt esteem
issues an academic study so that's
actually a great question yeah I think
there are are there are quite a few
things that you could do the fake it
till you make it I don't think that
that's a bad thing to do
but by itself it's it's really not going
to be sufficient right I think it's also
really important to see that there's
many other people in that and that that
mindset that I not everybody necessarily
goes through that some people don't go
through that who should go through that
because they're they're actually not
very good and they've just been told by
you know other people that they're
brilliant and maybe their class position
you know allows them to get away with
that or something like that but you know
I think a lot of people go through
doubts about themselves and their
abilities and their preparation and
stuff like that when it comes to
academic study in Jena
and philosophy in particular so knowing
that you're not the only one and that
it's a common occurrence I think can be
for many people quite helpful and I will
tell you that I myself at different
points have gone through that you know
and very often it was it was interesting
you know you you like you realize you're
gonna participate in something so I'll
give you a good example I was fortunate
enough to be the most junior scholar
selected for the last of Notre Dame's
Erasmus Institute faculty summer
fellowships and it was to study with
Alistair McIntyre at Notre Dame over the
summer and this this seminar thing and
there were 10 of us were brought
together and I think he told me
afterwards that one of the reasons why I
got in is because I was doing prison
education at the time and he had an
interest in prison education and I it
was also so the focus was practical
rationality and McIntyre always does
this thing where there's like three
different things he wants to compare one
was rational you know rational choice
theory or decision theory and its roots
and Hobbes and him in terms of desire
another was Aristotelian Thomism so
Aristotle would say Thomas and the third
was was Freud in Lacan and so the
psychoanalytic approach and I actually
you know was doing work that straddled
all three of those whereas almost all of
the other people in the seminar we're
doing one or two of those at most so you
know when I looked at the participants
and they're all like professors here and
there you know and they've got all these
publications and stuff like that you're
like oh man this is gonna be this is
gonna be kind of tough you know and you
know I'm kind of just nobody who happens
to be interested in this stuff and then
you get there and you meet the people
and you find out that you know they they
say dumb things and you're like oh okay
maybe maybe I'm not that that you know
backwards when it comes to this and and
they've got huge gaps in their own
education and
and you know and they've gone to the
good schools too and then you get you
could be like oh you know that proverb
about everybody puts their pants on one
leg at a time it turns out it's that way
in academia too so you know you can you
can tell yourself what I'm feeling is
perfectly normal and it doesn't have to
determine how things are gonna go for me
the other thing I would say too is you
know take chances I mean what's the
worst that's going to happen if you if
you say something in class people are
gonna laugh at you
okay well screw them they don't really
matter that much and if you learn
something out of it that that'll be good
all right mr. big weak knee do you by
the stoic idea that the only things with
being our material our immaterial things
like lect a real if they don't
participate in cause and effect I mean
so I'll answer the first one first no I
don't buy I'm not I'm not a materialist
right then again if you asked me what am
i I don't I don't really I don't worry
too much about those super foundational
things cuz that's not how I build my
philosophical views and I will say that
there are materialists who are not
reductive materialists you know people
who say well there has to be a material
basis for things but there must also be
something that like transcends that and
it comes out of the material whether
through emergence or some other way and
I'm attracted to those thinkers who
would include people like Lacan or
George Santayana and I think the Stoics
are arguably in that camp as well
because they're they're not reductive
materialists right they're not they're
they're not simply trying to break
everything down in that way they
actually the classic Stoics believe
there's gods you know and you got to
explain how how the hell does that
happen if you believe in some sort of
atomism or something like that you know
how do the head of the non-material
things have being being is not just what
what can you know have a material
presence
it doesn't seem like a big problem and I
mean does Elektra actually exert no
causality I mean they don't exert
causality on their own but they
certainly do seem to do so in relation
to other things don't think so
yeah I mean the stoic notions of
causality are kinda complicated and we
don't actually have the the source text
for that so we got to reconstruct what
they thought from other authors who are
generally not Stoics like Cicero or you
know a little bit of stuff from
Augustine Plutarch people like that all
right
Aquin do you have a personal theory of
consciousness or one that you find
appealing I don't really have a theory
of consciousness I you know it's
interesting people law on it for a long
time you know people would be like
talking about free will and you know
compatibilism and and you know
libertarianism and determinism and I'd
get into these things and I'd be like
well I guess I'm a compatibilist but I
don't really care that much about that
you know the sort of grounding stuff I'm
more interested and how does the will
actually work what what you know what
determines it how does it emerge from
determinism and then have a moment of
spontaneity or maybe some space of
freedom and then come back into it and
you know I'm more interested in those
sorts of things so I don't I don't know
that I actually can say that I have a
theory of consciousness as such I mean I
I know you know I sort of take
consciousness as something that we have
I don't I don't buy into the people who
say Oh consciousness can simply be
reduced to brain states or something
like that but I don't worry overly much
about the the problems of it so yeah all
right let's see what else we got here a
lot of questions I probably I should
warn
- I probably won't be able to answer all
these these questions because there's
more piling up then I'll be able to get
- boy what do you think about doing
videos on to lose in the future is a
difficult thinker many people struggle
with yeah I mean there's lots of
thinkers that I should do videos on it's
a matter of finding the time and the
inclination to do so people can
Commission me to do do videos you know
some of my Heidegger and nietzsche
videos are actually commissioned by by
people and so you know for the time
being when i'm shooting videos on is
stuff that I need for my my own students
in enrolled in my classes at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design or in the
prison program that MATC Milwaukee Area
Technical College has so I've been
filling in those sorts of gaps but you
know there's nothing to say that I
couldn't do videos on Toulouse it's just
you know it's just not a high priority
just like doing videos on Spinoza isn't
either uh you know but if somebody wants
to you know commissioned me and pay for
the time then I can change priorities
but but you know it's unfortunate
there's there's so many thinkers who I'd
like to do stuff on but finding the time
is really a challenge so I mean - loses
the lose is worth doing I'd say quien
Sarah what do you think are good
criticisms of Camus is a philosopher you
know I think Camus his commitment to
atheism is just sort of a thing that he
starts out with and I don't think he
ever really looks at religious thinkers
without having the blinders on which
isn't to say that you'd have to like be
a theist in order to do that William
James is a good example of somebody who
I think is better in that respect what
else
I mean he's he writes I don't I don't
mind his writing I actually enjoy
reading his stuff
but a lot of people find the style in
which he writes kind of convoluted and
annoying so I guess that's a criticism
it's not a criticism I make but it's a
criticism I hear made a lot you know I
think a lot of people do criticism
criticized him as well for like not
taking as clear of a stand on certain
things as as other people but that's not
that's not that big of a problem for me
I think that when it comes to the
complicated matters of our actual lives
which is what he was really interested
in we're not gonna make it all perfectly
fit I actually like him quite a bit he's
a he's one of my favorite interlocutors
in many respects especially when it
comes to politics dan the man coming
with an update did my presentation for
my senior thesis for the Mississippi
Academy of Science and got an award for
presenting feeling pretty good nice job
that is that's really great yeah hold on
to the good feeling well if you've got
it and you've got something there that
nobody can take away from you so that
that's wonderful nomina swear did you
get Hegel's lectures they seem hard to
find I got I got most of them at used
bookstores or I ordered them years ago I
don't know where you find them today I
assume that that you know they're
available on Amazon but I haven't done
any looking for a long time because I
I've already got the stuff I need all
right if I can't if I don't have it at
home I can walk down the street to
Marquette University which is about 12
blocks from here and I have library
privileges there they've given me
courtesy faculty status as a as a you
know local scholar at Marquette so
that's that's kind of nice I don't know
where you'd find him though
alright Frank you phrenic would you show
which I'm sure I butchered your name
there what contemporary philosophers do
you read and find them interesting or
inspiring well I mentioned you know
Alistair McIntyre of course big fan of
him there's quite a few people who do
really great history of philosophy that
I think is of great contemporary
relevance so you know my colleague Chris
Gill over at Exeter when I say colleague
I mean that we're both on the modern
stoicism team Julia honest is really
great you know Margaret graver you know
there's there's quite a few people in
that sort of doing history of philosophy
but it's not it's not the history of
philosophy that's was like trying to
trace up where people's ideas are saying
hey look these ideas are relevant to the
present a long is still around major
contributor to study of Hellenistic
philosophy you know in in contemporary
continental philosophy somebody who I I
like reading is a Gavin
I don't read an awful lot of like you
know cutting-edge contemporary stuff in
part because a lot of the people are
gonna be you know forgotten in 20 years
yeah just looking back at what what
continental philosophy was like and who
all the rising stars were you know 20
years ago and I was a grad student I
think that's the safe bet
yeah I mean you know I kind of read
around and a lot of stuff comes my way
because people send it to me so alright
Marko's what is so intricately
satisfying about philosophy well I don't
know that it is for everybody certainly
my my students are kind of half-and-half
on that
and in philosophy isn't always fun to
read all the time anyway and it really
depends on who you're reading I think
part of it is the idea of having sort of
systematic viewpoints on things that are
built out because we human beings do
have a desire to understand things and
to understand them not just in an off on
oh I got the answer there let's move
let's move on but in sort of a more
comprehensive way so I think that that's
probably part of it exercising your mind
is probably part of it as well but I
don't know that's that's a good question
ken Sarah who do I think are some
worthwhile conservative or libertarian
philosophers to read to balance out
leftist thought well I wouldn't read him
to balance out leftist thought I would
read them because they're worth they're
actually worth reading at least you know
most of them some of them are worth
reading just so like you know what
people are talking about even though
their philosophy is not very good yeah
so I mean with libertarianism obviously
Nozick is is really important there's
you know there's actually a lot of
discussion today going on about
libertarianism and you know the whole
there's there's this website
bleeding-heart libertarianism that Matsu
elinsky got started it's worth reading
around in that you know that's sort of
contemporary stuff I don't know you know
when it comes to conservative
philosophers I find people who are
movement conservatives generally kind of
boring and I don't know I don't know
that you know they're worth spending
that much time on conservative doesn't
really mean the same thing now as it did
say thirty years ago looking at where
things are
but if you're if you're talking about
like the vast sweep of like you know the
last couple hundred years it's worth
reading people who were considered
traditionalists to see what what they
were actually saying because then you
can see that the people who are being
called traditionalists today or who are
advocating positions today are really
doing nothing particularly new and they
were like conservative conservatives
right you know the French Revolution was
a huge mistake and and you know we need
to go back to this hierarchical
authority thing so that would include
you know the French ones all the way up
to like Shar Amara but that's you know
that's not particularly contemporary you
know there's there's Russell Kirk the
conservative mind which which is kind of
good to read through he's tracing out
some interesting things but yeah I'd
have to think about that more all right
Matt Tucker I'm reading Humes on the
standard of taste my teacher is asking
us to to examine the intersection of art
and politics any idea where he's going
with this not really not really because
I'd have to have it a little bit more
context so Humes aesthetic theory is is
you know in a way it's like the person
who's got a good taste can zero in more
and more and more on what's what's
actually taste a bowl right so how do
you apply that to politics I don't
really know
not enough quite sure they're all right
I often discuss this is from Mark Martin
Costa I often discuss and criticize the
academic system on Twitter are there any
books critical of higher education
you're fond of I'm not you know I'm not
I haven't like read any contemporary
stuff about that and I mean the last
book that I read that was particularly
good in that respect was academically
adrift no I think that was published ten
years ago right and that's you know
Richard Arum and I think rosca is his
collaborator got to meet him actually
at the he came to the Culinary Institute
of America where my wife was at that
time either an assistant dean or a
director and she brought a man and we
got to have some some you know a meal
together and chat about what was going
on and at that time I was doing a lot of
work with the collegiate learning
assessment that he used as an important
part of his argument but I I'm not you
know I don't I I barely have the time to
read the stuff that I want to read so
I'm not I'm not drawing this primarily
out of books it's more just being an
insider in the industry so all right
Annika Lee how hard is it to do a PhD in
philosophy compared to studying it as an
undergrad thanks wow that's a good
question that totally depends on where
where you're going all right I mean some
undergraduate education might actually
be better or more rigorous than some
graduate programs depending on what what
they're doing so I mean I can tell you
what you have to do in a ph.d program
and and you know generally you don't
just go right into the ph.d program I
actually think it's a big mistake to go
right from undergrad into a ph.d program
because you miss a lot of stuff along
the way in the you know desire to be a
go-getter and all that you know so let's
talk about a master's right first you
you have to get your masters and used to
be in the old days that you actually had
to like take a comprehensive examination
nowadays that's usually been phased out
but you still have to do about 30 hours
of graduate coursework six of which
might be working on your master's thesis
you have to write a master's thesis
which is a you know more extended
research paper than say a senior thesis
or dissertation as they call it in
England and you know master's thesis
probably going to be anywhere from 40 to
120 pages of
work eventually produced and then as a
PhD student you're going to also take
another 30 hours of coursework you might
have to do some language requirements
you might also have to do those at the
Masters level or you might not depending
on the program you have to produce a
prospectus and then the committee you
know that's that back and forth and then
you actually get to write your
dissertation and a dissertation is
basically a book and it could be you
know it could be short like 120 pages it
could be long - about 375 pages I've
seen dissertations go to 700 pages and
you know you have to put a lot of work
into it ideally you wind up with
something that's publishable but many
dissertations don't don't actually turn
into books when they do you can tell
they're obviously a dissertation because
of the way it's written and the
footnoting so you know there there's a
lot of work involved you also have to
think about how you would these days
it's very important to think about how
you would finance your education because
there's there's a lot of places that
used to like you know have a much more
funding than they do for graduate
students and now maybe maybe they don't
you know taking on student loans can
sometimes be a big burden so yeah that
hopefully gives you some idea about it
all right let me scroll back up to where
that question was um Lenny penny what
are my ideas on post-modernism won't
lead to something good or something bad
well there isn't one thing called
post-modernism so that really can't be
answered a lot of people throw the term
around but have no no real clue but what
it means because it's not the same thing
as relativism it's not the same thing as
Marxism it's not the same thing as
intersectionality there's there's no a
there's no post-modernism out there
that's going to lead to something I mean
if they're right we're actually
you know when people were talking about
post-modernism they weren't saying oh
it's it's coming and it's this program
that we have they're saying we're in
postmodernity right now
that was what leotard was saying back
you know when he wrote the postmodern
condition and that's what Jamis said see
what he brought out post-modernism the
cultural logic of late capitalism and
this is before the the turn of the
century so you know there is it's not
the kind of question that can really be
be answered of the the em vlog did lemme
nasus have correspondence with the the
vienna circle I don't know I'm not a
loving a scholar that would be an
interesting thing if he did but I don't
know why he would I mean VidCon Stein
Russell and white had weren't in the
Vienna circle you're thinking at people
like card app and you know people who
actually were in Vienna mikan-chan came
from Vienna but he moved to England
right all right uh Alex brings up Robert
Sokolowski is as a phenomenologist who's
worth studying yeah that's that's true
he's a he's a contemporary one now that
I think about it to somebody else would
be like in Sokolowski 's age group would
be adrian pepper Zach who I don't know
if he's still alive or not if he is he's
in his 90s he taught at Loyola for a
very long time he did work on levied us
and on Hegel and on phenomenology and
quite a few other things as well all
right Ken Sarah could explain or direct
you had any good explanation of cow Moos
ethics of quantity I don't do secondary
literature very much you know like I've
said you know it comes up in in mythos
if assess there's you know in I don't
know that he actually like sticks with
it so I wouldn't I wouldn't worry overly
much about it Gabriel are poets in the
broad
cents considered a separate class of
artists they seem to have intrinsic
knowledge and wisdom about how to make
certain things by nature intuitively not
learn its skill well that's that's a
very romantic vision of poets as it
turns out
poets are like any other skilled artist
lots and lots and lots of disciplined
work before you get good at it you
should you should go and take a poetry
class sometime one or they're writing
poetry and get your stuff critiqued and
then you'll you'll quickly you'll
quickly get rid of this idea that they
they know how to make certain things by
nature and or intuitively there's so
much skill that goes into it I mean you
can have talents but just like with
music or just like with art
merely having the talent that gets you
in the door and then it's lots and lots
of work so robbery is circuit is there a
clear boundary between philosophy and
political science if so what where is it
there isn't a clear boundary I mean it's
it's it's one of those things where you
go to one University and the curriculum
will be divided one way go to another
it'll be divided another way I mean you
can say that philosophy doesn't do the
quantitative analysis but that's not all
political science there's also political
theory right so it's it's with most
disciplines the boundary lines between
philosophy and that discipline are going
to be rather contested and permeable and
anybody who tries to tell you here's
where the dividing line is is usually
kind of selling your line of BS
all right I'm gonna start taking
questions more from people who haven't
been asking them so I can get to as many
interlocutors as possible find me a film
I can't refuse any tips for reading
Kant's first critique yes
set aside a lot of time use use whatever
resources
you find available to help you out with
it it is some some pretty dense stuff
with can't you know I always tell
students two things about Conte and his
writing it's like cracking a code is the
first one you got to figure out what
what is terminology means and once that
happens a lot of things start to fall
into place and it becomes more it
becomes less difficult to understand
what he's saying then there's also the
let's call it wait a second does he
really believe that sort of incredulity
that goes along with with things and and
the answer is yes he does in fact
believe that so like when we're talking
about Kant's moral philosophy saying the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
and he says essentially that you know
Duty has really nothing to do with
happiness and that you know as rational
beings that's not why we were given
reason to be happy at whereas most other
philosophers say yes rational beings
there's some connection to happiness
people are like this can't really
believe then you're like yeah yeah
that's what the guy actually does think
so you know I would I would approach it
with those two things umm what else I
mean I don't really have too much other
advice to help you out with it it's
gonna be a slog don't get down on
yourself if you don't understand exactly
what he's what he's referencing as a
matter of fact I would like I would like
read through sections all the way
through even if you don't understand
what's going on and then go back and
reread right all right
alright here we go here's another new
person sticker and ooh can you explain
how everyone is worth the same if they
are I think like a drug addict versus a
surgeon if you have to choose who has to
die from an ethical viewpoint I mean you
can say that they're both they both have
the same intrinsic human dignity but
that if we have to choose between them
that we'll choose the one who's more
valuable to the community those are
there's no incompatibility between those
two things because they're two different
ways of looking at it alright they're
just not looking at the person in the
same way so Steven asks I've just
finished reading the transcendence of
the ego and I'm a bit confused and
starts rewriting in the phenomenological
reduction would you mind explaining how
it fits into starts work it's been a
long time since I've read that so I
don't I don't remember enough about it
to tell you anything with that Watergate
is it bad that I have no questions
concerning philosophy because you have
no questions at this time concerning
philosophy doesn't mean that you won't
ever have questions concerning
philosophy so you know and it's it's not
as if everybody has to be doing
philosophy all the time so I don't see
anything wrong with that Bree Berta X
are you familiar with homens meta
critique of Conte haven't read homens
since graduate school I remember he
seemed pretty interesting and I don't
remember all that much after that
so no dipbrow dr. Sadler please simplify
dairy does spectra leti I don't know how
you'd simplify it you know I don't even
remember you know which which particular
works that that shows up in you know the
stuff that I'm more interested in with
Derrida is less his later works and more
the earlier stuff but I don't spend a
lot of time with with Derrida at this
point Thomas More am i aware of Brian
Magee I am indeed aware of Matt Brian
Magee his autobiography confessions of a
philosopher super interesting but that's
great I haven't read him I imagine it
probably would be interesting all right
let's see here let's find some new stuff
when we can come back up here Anthony
what do you make of the central theses
of jean-luc Mari owns God without being
now that's a work that that I haven't
looked at for a while as well I mean I
like his discussion of the function of
the icon I thought that was really quite
good I think that Mario buying you know
trying to use Heidegger and and doing
all this this stuff about you know God
has to be without being I actually found
a lot of that kind of ridiculous myself
it's it's you know it reminds me of this
thing from from live myths where
aliveness that philosophies are
generally true and what they affirm and
and false and what they deny and her
just got the cat jumping up sassy Mario
is you know he's within that that sort
of yeah say hi to everybody says he's
within that that sort of hi to Gary and
you know metaphysics is bad kind of
shtick
we're gonna save we're gonna save the
world from the meta physicians and I
just never found that plausible at all
I like the examples that he used I like
his his discussion towards the end of
the function of the the homily in you
know manifest manifestation so you know
it's it's it's kind of any other you
know he's got kind of an interesting
excellent Earp rotational prodigal son
thing and they
as well but I just I don't buy into
Mario's project you know and having met
the guy and interacted with them I you
know for somebody who's so big on the
metaphysics of charity the way he
behaved towards graduate students not
myself but because I spoke French with
him so I was I was like in the okay
group was really kind of shitty and and
I didn't I didn't like it and then I saw
him quite a bit at the lumen christi
institute and you know ya never really
saw him as a his thing is all that
viable francis s - I think Hegel's
absolute logic was right in the idea of
the self examination of the reason
proving the necessity of reason for
absolute knowledge I don't really buy
into I'll put it to you this way I don't
really buy into the sort of absolutist
project in in Hegel I think that he's
got some really cool observations along
the way of the dialectic and he's very
insightful about a lot of stuff but like
the overarching big project of I'm you
know I'm enunciated what absolute spirit
has as worked out I just don't buy it
history never ended I think that a lot
of a lot of what Hegel is doing is is
really like I said really interesting
really innovative stuff but oftentimes
the grounding for it it's just not there
even though he desperately wants it to
be there and it doesn't have to be there
in order for it to be interesting or
useful I think all right Loren Crawford
do you have a philosophical reading
recommendations for grief I've been
struggling okay yeah
it depends on what you want to look at I
mean if you want to see what
philosophers have had to say about
sadness and grief which might not you
know might not be very consoling to you
but but could be could be helpful I
would say look at this
Daleks look at Cicero's tusculum
disputations particularly the
discussions about death and grief the
book one and I think what book book for
there are you know and you can also
think about looking at the examples of
philosophers who had to deal with grief
again the Cicero is a great example is
his daughter who was very smart and very
capable he appears to have been closer
to her than he was to his son Marcus she
died Thalia and and he writes about this
in his works that part of what he's
doing is consoling himself and taking
his mind off of the things that
otherwise would be occupying him by
writing philosophy I'm a big fan of
Rilke as well and Rilke talks quite a
bit about about death and about grieving
and sadness and puts it in a different
framework some of his poetry is about
that particularly the Duino elegies so
you know but I'll say this grieving is
always is always difficult and one can
only be helped out so much so a good bit
of it is just other people being there
and saying oh you know I I'm here for
you or it's okay to be sad or just won't
be forever and sometimes just shutting
the hell up and just be there quite
frankly you know and I don't know I
don't really have too much else to say
about about that
all right to do let's see what else we
have
Neha Ravi do you have any tips for
leading a more wholesome life um well I
guess you have to have an idea what your
wholesome life is like so that's
probably worth some scrutiny you know a
whole I mean a good life is is I'm sort
of a pluralist when it comes to that you
know I'm I'm not with the Stoics vert
you know you cannot live a wonderful
life just by having virtue or something
like that I'm much more like Aristotle
you know well virtues grade virtuous
activity is important meaningfulness is
important but relationships are also
important and you do need a little bit
of you know wealth to like not be out on
the street and have your life totally
suck and and you know there's other
things as well health is important and
all of that so I think you wanna you
want to think about what what are the
components of this wholesome life and
then what you have to do to to move
yourself towards it and generally that's
going to be some intentional way of
living and there's lots of there's lots
of ways to go about that you know again
I I'm kind of a pluralist when it comes
to those sorts of things you could you
could pick up on what the Stoics have to
say and use some of what they've got you
can look at what the later platon us
like like Plutarch have to say you could
take other things that are more
contemporary there's all sorts of great
resources for it but but it's going to
have to be an intentional way of living
[Music]
roppa asks do you think that a
philosopher's actions specifically their
shortcomings should affect how they're
viewed for example heidegger's
anti-semitism or Zoe's perversions etc
etc or Nietzsche not being the
ubermensch we could say or Descartes
actually being a cooler guy
towards animals in reality than you
would expect from his books yeah I mean
it depends right I think if somebody's
like let's say we take urban COPI right
major contributor to the study and
popularization of logic I don't really
know anything about Colby's personal
life and I don't really care and I don't
want it doesn't matter you know if I
found out that that he was into child
pornography it wouldn't change the the
the logic books I mean I'd say well I I
don't want that guy you know near me but
he's really a degenerate but it doesn't
it doesn't affect the way that he does
logic it you know it's it's probably
more important when we get to like
things where it's it's much more about
human beings and society so like
philosophy of history or philosophy of
human nature ethics obviously social
political philosophy right so when we
find out that say for example Martin
Luther King cheated on his wife does
that mean that you know we should look
at the I have a dream speech or letter
from a Birmingham jail or his is a
diagnosis of social dynamics differently
no probably not
we can say that he was flawed and but if
we find out that you know if we can't
get talk specifically about fidelity and
marriage then we might be like a I don't
know that this guy's you know the one to
talk about that and and so you know the
answer is yes and no it depends on what
the subject matter is and it depends on
how much the bad behavior is affecting
it or kind of invalidating it right so I
think I think it's probably enough to
say about that
Thomas is any advice about how to deal
with the terror of pandemic virus well
we're not at the Terror point yet I
think the terror that's being produced
is largely by
governmental responses to it quarantines
right so you know in China there you
could say there is quite a bit of Terror
going on and then there's the prejudice
against Chinese people or people who are
perceived as being Chinese that that's
happening as well and we have to be
careful I mean it's interesting there's
there's like people who are Filipinos I
noticed this in my Twitter stream we're
like hey you all need to stop you know
being so concerned about coronavirus and
looking at me as if I'm a threat to you
and wondering why I don't have a mask on
I'm not even Chinese I'm Filipino but
we're you know you're kind of falling
into this and I think when we have these
concerns it becomes really easy for
there to be you know it's almost like it
Prime's things for think for for for
matters to go downhill it's sort of like
you know we we had this big scare about
the swine flu back in I think it was
2009 came to be nothing right could it
could have gone really bad but it came
to be nothing and we had all these
people that were starting to panic about
it that panic itself can become the
driving force and so you know I'll give
you another example
it was non non disease related if you
remember y2k y2k is you know the year
2000 there was this big worry that all
of our electronic devices were going to
quit - quit functioning and all our
computers were gonna melt down and
everything was gonna like grind to a
technological stop so I was living in a
trailer park at that time in southern
Illinois as I was going to graduate
school and it was one of the better
trailer parks but it was still a trailer
park and so they were there you know
quite a few people in the park who are
you know buying into conspiracy theories
many many people were heavily armed in
that trailer park as a matter
fact the FBI you know is know as ATF did
a raid on one of the trailers and people
were running guns out of it
there's a whole story in there that
could be told and that was that was in
our trailer park so I was thinking to
myself you know I don't think the
computers are actually gonna fail but
all it takes is like somebody to do
something nutty and then all these other
people who are primed for the end of the
world they happen to like get out and
start doing stuff and shooting the place
up and man this is gonna suck
unfortunately nothing happened but I
think that's that that that sort of
thing can sometimes be the case all
right our brain hurts a lot asks am i
familiar with millennial youtubers like
contra points or philosophy tube do i
watch their content so I'm familiar with
them
I don't watch their content because I
you know my time is is rather limited
during the day and I you know there's
very few podcasts or video channels that
I actually do watch and it's generally
gonna be stuff that I can try to learn
something from the popularizing stuff I
just don't see as worth my time
and I know that my work there is one
that I watched with philosophy tube so
when he did on the master-slave
dialectic and he we had some exchange he
referenced my work and some of it but
you know for me I'm not into that sort
of thing because Hegel's way more than
the master-slave dialectic and I think
you know at this point in time we
probably if we want to popularize Hegel
we should talk about other things like
recognition which is what actually is
you know the master-slave dialectic is a
tiny little moment within or we should
talk about the other other interesting
parts of the phenomenology so you know
they're doing their thing they're
actually getting way more views of
course because it's high production and
sort of easy to get into content is not
the sort of thing I do you know I
concentrate on
sort of I'm not that interested in
production stuff obviously you know I
got a mic nowadays but I'm kind of slow
in that respect and I'm interested in
providing the best content possible the
stuff that's actually grounded in the
texts and helping people to understand
things and so we're Canada you know
we're moving in separate paths and and I
just you know I don't have that much to
to do with them so yeah all right a
retro gamer do I consider Spinoza too
dense like a galleon conceptions to
present from his ethics or even to
pre-modern in his deliberation of the
affectation of ordinary men I don't
think Spinoza is actually that tough I
think that he didn't do himself a favor
by putting the ethics in that more a
geometrical you know started sort of
thing but you know when you actually
when you figure out what he's doing
again once you crack the code it's
really not that complicated and what
happened with conda's I was remarking
earlier you could say does he really
believe this stuff yes but knows it
really does believe that stuff you know
there is one substance of which there
are you know these attributes two of
which we grasp and we are modes of that
substance and yeah that's that's his
doctrine I don't think it would be
difficult to do stuff on Spinoza I think
it'd also be quite easy to do it on his
other works like the you know tract
honesty alone eco politicus or the
principles of Cartesian philosophy it's
just a matter of finding the time you
know and I think what he has to say is
interesting I don't buy it but I don't
buy can't I hope I Bentham and I don't
buy you know a lot of the stuff that's
in Nietzsche but it's really interesting
you know and worth worth presenting all
right let's see here
candis asks do I feel the exercise I've
been doing of late has enhanced my
intellect no not really I mean when I go
to the gym and I and I've been going to
the gym for two years so I guess that is
of late and and I you know I'll go
through periods where I'm able to like
do it three to five times a week
regularly and then something will happen
you know sometimes it's it's a family
related stuff you know people are
getting sick or we got a 10-2 different
family issues or the animals sometimes
it's getting overloaded with with work
sometimes I get sick so it kind of comes
and goes when I go to the gym I'm doing
usually one of two types of workouts one
is on the whate circuit and one is doing
cardio stuff on other machines and I'll
put in my headphones and I'm listening
to my metal playlist and you know
oftentimes like in-between stuff getting
on Twitter and seeing what people are
saying and so it's kind of like me time
I'm not doing a lot of intellectual work
I'm not listening to podcasts I'm not
like thinking about you know Plato and
what he has to say about stuff so the
activity itself I mean I suppose being
in better physical condition is probably
helpful but I don't know that it you
know nobody's ever like I've never had
the sort of medical staff that that
focus on my brain treatment my brain
what is a brain not brain States brain
health or anything like that
so you know I I don't know that it would
actually make any any difference but
it's a good to do you know I'm the
reason why workout is I want to live a
long life and doing the kinds of things
that I'm doing cardiovascular stuffer
for you know
that my my system and lifting weights
which is good you know for strength and
also for the bone density and stuff like
that
and then you know when I have time I'm
gonna start doing some other stuff you
know flexibility and and who knows what
else I'll end up doing I want to have a
body that is not going to be that my
sole source of attention as its rotting
and dying away and breaking down when I
would like to actually be doing
productive work and spending time with
my my kids and family and friends I want
you know I'm I'm approaching 50 I would
like to live to 90 and have the decent
quality of life now whether that's gonna
happen or not I don't know you know I
did a lot of damage to my body with you
know in my teens and twenties with well
I'm even even into my 30s to some degree
with smoking and drinking when I could
like get away with it and eating the
wrong kind of stuff fortunately I also
did a lot of exercise at that time as
well so you know maybe some of these
things balance each other out and I'm no
longer smoking and I don't drink very
much anymore so you know who knows and I
I don't I don't quite know about my
genes I know quite a bit about my
biological father and their family seems
to be quite long lived I don't know that
much about my biological mother and all
her relatives so who knows and and I
could you know I could get sick tomorrow
and die of something but I'd like to
even the odds as much as I can I can do
that so I'm not like you know in in the
when I was younger I was like exercising
because I really liked exercise and I
wanted to be like you know frankly I
wanted to be like a Nietzsche nuber man
show on time and and I wanted to be able
to like you know fight and and you know
compete and all this or stuff now I
don't really care about that stuff now
it's just about trying to stay on track
alright Zachary thoughts on completing
an online BA in philosophy can online
just
gushin posts makeup for in-person
dialogue I'm liking Arizona State
University you know I teach online it
totally depends on the program and the
instructor there are crappy face-to-face
classes where the discussion is garbage
there are great online courses where the
discussion is is you know incredible and
then there's everything in between I
don't know enough about Arizona State to
be able to to say anything if they're
like southern New Hampshire University
where I looked at teaching with them
it's all basically canned content
they've already built their curriculum
out and the professors don't really get
to do much other than lead discussion
sessions that could be good that could
be bad depending on how they've built
the content out and how the people are
are interacting so I don't I don't
really know I there's not much I can I
can actually say about that all right
looks like I've got my power cord is not
properly plugged in so bear with me for
a moment while I see what's what with
this thing down here there we go I can't
afford to run out of juice right okay
where were we
Quinn asks how should or can we balance
reading widely with reading deeply well
and that's a good one here's the crappy
bottom line given the the amount that's
out there you're probably not gonna be
able to do either one of them to the
degree that you'd like to be able to do
it so you know it's it's kind of a
pragmatic thing how much do you want to
do you you cannot read everything that's
available anyway so you've got to make
some you know decisions about who you're
gonna read and how much time you're
actually gonna put into it and there may
be some thinkers who at first when you
approach you're like oh this is garbage
I'm not gonna spend my time on this but
it turns out later on you'd find out
that it was in fact worth worth spending
time on you know example I use every
time I found Aristotle incredibly boring
until I got to graduate school and part
of that was my own maturation process
and part of it was learning Greek and
reading him in Greek and so you know
that may be the case for you I would say
that you do want to you do want to try
to read deeply with at least a few
philosophers and you know the ones that
you pick right now you may look back on
in 10 years and say why did I pick that
person you know who you know what was
going at in my head that I thought that
that was really what I ought to be
focused on and that's okay that's this
part of the that's part of the process I
think right made of clay asks are there
any philosophers that may have a
justified view on the use of violence
when to use it when not use it I think
there's plenty of them you know if you
think about it like Aristotle Aristotle
thinks that you're gonna have to use
violence and in some cases right he even
talks in the politics is a really
interesting thing so this came up in a
Twitter conversation a little while back
about Spartans right there's all these
people that these days these bros that
are like oh man Spartan there's Spartan
that the actual Spartans were just a hot
mess their society was was you know
terrible for the people who lived in it
they really didn't have much freedom and
they they did manage to save Greece in a
couple cases from the Persians and also
from the yoke of the Athenians but yeah
I mean uncritical admiration of others
Martin's is really kind of a silly thing
because 99 99 percent of the the the
bros who would like you know I'm gonna
be a Spartan man if they were in Sparta
they'd be a helot and they'd be living a
crap life and if they try to do the
Spartan training they would be so
traumatized that it wouldn't work
Aristotle talks about the Spartans he
says that they went wrong primarily they
were very good at war and they over
specialized and they in essence made a
teleological mistake they thought that
life is fundamentally about that not
realizing that war and violence and
force is for something else and so they
structured their entire society around
becoming the toughest guys on the block
and lost everything else that they
needed in the process so you know
there's there there are justifications
for violence Aristotle again and the
politics even talks about the need for
some sort of carceral system so it's
kind of you know granted that for a lot
of philosophers that yeah there's gonna
be violence a question is well when when
should we be violent and who should be
violent and and for what reason all
right there are some philosophers who
are like total pacifists but they may
they may sometimes make exceptions for
the state you know think about Socrates
who taught the doctrine that it's better
to to suffer harm than than to do harm
to others right he fought in the
Peloponnesian wars so you know what's
going on there
Zakaria what's your take on Carl Schmitt
somebody who I haven't thought about for
quite a long time I never found his
stuff all that interesting I mean it
basically boils down to the the you know
the state of emergency becoming a
regular thing and the friend versus
enemy dilemma and that the fact that
liberal democracy has trouble defending
itself so
mr. Dharam paji can I elucidate the
screening process and PhD programs in
anthropology or philosophy I wouldn't
have any idea about anthropology
screening process and philosophy I
assume what you're talking about is
people applying to be graduate students
so you send in your materials and then
the committee in whatever way they're
gonna do it and it's probably gonna vary
considerably from place to place to
place gets together there and makes
their decisions and then lets you know
and that's you know there's much more to
say about it than that I think each
place is gonna be quite a bit different
rade have I read Bataille if so what do
I think of the guy well the guy himself
was great
pretty crazy it's a guy right I like his
I like his stuff I like his writings
he's he's a very difficult to categorize
person right so I think he's worth
reading it's one of those things where
you you you read and and you're probably
not gonna buy into the whole but tie-in
point of view but but there are some
very interesting insights there to take
from it Stephen Warren I've been deep
into Kierkegaard lately currently on the
sickness onto death how do you think
modern Christianity could benefit by
assimilating Kierkegaard's ideas well
that's a good question
I mean Kierkegaard thought that that
most modern Christianity was really not
Christian it was just being a member of
a club and so it's it's not even really
that clear how much of a how much a
existing church could in fact be
Christian for Kierkegaard's point of
view so you know if they took that
seriously they I suppose they would they
would without abandoning you know all
the stuff that goes and does a parish
life or denominational life or all that
stuff they would really focus on
the sort of like being called before God
as an individual and this would apply
not just a Protestants but to Catholics
or Orthodox because because we're all or
all individuals and man I think it you
know there'd be a lot of people if they
really took it seriously they would
produce quite a few changes in behavior
because you know if you think about what
the Sermon on the Mount commands hmm
most Christians don't don't come
anywhere near to living up to that nor
even acknowledge as far as I can tell
that that's the should be the governing
North's guiding them you know it's very
difficult to practice even with people
you like let alone enemies or strangers
so yeah it would produce some massive
changes alright let's see here
Bastian does Nietzsche believe in the
possibility of every drive becoming
satisfied or used in unison or is
suppression necessary contrast this with
Kierkegaard's belief that with God all
is possible I think there's no need to
contrast it with Kierkegaard that with
God all is possible doesn't mean that
every single Drive is what God would
focus on need to does not think that
every single Drive can be satisfied or
used in unison there's always going to
be some subordination doesn't
necessarily have to be repression
although probably it will be but there's
going to be some something dominating
and something dominated so the question
is you know what's going to be what and
where is it going to get its guidance
from or what's going to determine that I
think right wicked fatigue can you name
some practical application for
philosophy like applied philosophy well
there's all these philosophy of areas
right so you know philosophy of sport
for example what constitutes
sportsmanship that's that's a
definitional question and we could say
is there a metaphysical basis first
Bertrand ship is a purely something
social well you know we get into all
those sorts of interesting theoretical
questions and but that's very applied
when we want to say that person should
not have been find and there shouldn't
have been a penalty for unsportsmanlike
conduct there's all sorts of practical
applications for philosophy and there's
many fields that are applied philosophy
all right
GTA films are you a fan of Vince
Gilligan's fiction so that's the a
better better call Saul and Breaking Bad
guy right yeah we we got into Breaking
Bad my wife and I after the series had
already been running for a while and we
watched to catch up and then watched it
all the way through this series end and
we've been watching better call Saul and
we haven't seen the El Camino movie but
you know because we're busy and we've
put it off until we have the time to do
so but yeah I like I like his stuff it's
it's interesting Samuel martsin when one
is young say first year at uni is a
philosophy like egoism more helpful to
follow and then as the aging process
takes place a transformation towards
something like stoicism I wouldn't say
so why would you you know why wouldn't
you if one is better than the other why
wouldn't you want to move towards that
right away I mean it's the idea that
you're gonna like packing your
experiences of being an egoistic
exploiter and jerk and then later you're
gonna like haven't come to come to a
Epictetus moment like a come-to-jesus
moment and then change your your your
point of view I mean if you think
something is a good way of living pick
it up now you know if you don't then
you'll probably never get into that
let's see here
let's find some new stuff to do a lot of
back-and-forth stuff Virginia what is
the connection between the Theseus myth
the labyrinth and mythology and the
Phaedo mother really isn't a connection
between the Theseus myth and mythology
in the Phaedo mythology there's like a
little discussion about how mythology is
like misanthropy right so I don't I
don't see those is connected unless I'm
not remembering something let's see to
do to do now Zemus what theory of
predestination and election do you hold
to what do you think of negative
reprobation i don't even know what
negative reprobation means so obviously
I don't think about it
well I think that that we have freewill
so I think that there's you know choices
we make and we make them within context
that we've been provided with with the
resources that we've been provided with
which then feeds back into whether we
have more resources the next time around
or less resources whether we handicap
ourselves or you know put ourselves in a
better position and I think that the way
that we behave with others does that as
well so yeah let's see
Jimmy from Hong Kong RWD Dubois and
France fun own part of your plans for
future core concept videos that's a good
question for known definitely because
one of the classes I'm going to be
teaching for Milwaukee institute of art
design in the fall as an online class is
existentialist philosophy and literature
and fun ona is one of the people that
I'm gonna include in that I don't do a
lot of work on african-american
philosophy I have taught courses on it
when I was back at Fayetteville State
University I do like reading Du Bois but
I haven't I've never like created videos
on him but I don't see any reason why I
couldn't it would be it'd be a matter of
like fine same thing with like Spinoza
though finding the time if I'm not
teaching it in a class it seems like
more and more my videos tend to be
focused on a man let's see here skipped
down there's some conversation going on
there a lot of back-and-forth stuff John
Ortiz why is philosophy not value in the
market thought thoughts well a lot of
things aren't valued in them in the
market depends on what market you're
talking about of course philosophy is
valued in quite a few markets you know
there's quite a few people who are in
business that have philosophy degrees
you'd have to actually like do the
looking around and you'll find them and
philosophers do sometimes get brought in
as consultants and not just in ethics
but in in in other things as well
so it depends on how you're doing
philosophy it's better it's better to
like it's probably better to like think
about these things less as like capital
P philosophy covering every single thing
and think about different areas you're
probably not gonna you know get a lot of
traction out there getting hired by
people if you say well all I do is focus
on this this little conversation that's
been happening among analytic
philosophers in these five articles with
these particular isms yeah nobody's
really gonna hire you for that or you
know if we could bash the Continentals
as well we could say you know what I do
is immanent ich well what the hell is at
you better be able to explain it or
nobody's gonna be interested in that you
know a lot of it are you supposed to is
an inability to explain what it is that
you do to other people because I don't
have any problem actually I I have more
clients coming to me that I can easily
accommodate some of the time many of
whom are coming to me from from business
fields so let's see here to do we're
getting about five the five minute mark
Andrew says I defined myself as an
eclectic in my philosophical beliefs I
don't define myself as an eclectic I
characterize myself as an eclectic could
I talk more about that and why and what
philosophies I admire and follow I have
an entire video on that but I'll put it
to you this way so there's there's two
ways of being an eclectic one is to like
say ah a little bit of this a little bit
of this a little bit of this a little
bit of this smorgasbord eclecticism
smorgasbord of course is that you know
when you walk in you think of it as a
buffet right and you just kind of pick
and choose and the stuff doesn't
necessarily go with each other another
word for the kind of eclecticism that
that I'm into would be pluralism and
Cicero is a perfect example of that you
learn different philosophical
and you take from them what you think is
actually valid and you take as much as
you can from them and try to see if you
can you know harmonize it with the other
things and at certain points you do have
to make decisions you have to say well I
think the Stoics are wrong on this and
the Aristotelian czar right or more
right you do have to set up sort of
dividing lines but you you try as best
as you can through this back and forth
process to to produce something that
isn't just you know like it said a
buffet tray of stuff right like a
charcuterie plate I mean who do I drawn
a lot well you know existentialist
dialectical thinkers you know you notice
me talking about James I like the
pragmatists I like some classical
American philosophy there's even a few
analytics that I like you know you know
and then you know sort of what we call
tradition constituted rationalities
using McIntyre's term Aristotelian ism
stoicism platonism even the Epicureans
to some degree you know there's there's
a lot but it's generally like play
favorites with them you could say all
right Linden where do I stand on the
Achrafieh disagreement between Plato and
Aristotle so what is the Achrafieh
disagreement first of all we should
specify that Achrafieh is often
translated as weakness of will you could
call it also failure of commitment you
know failure of choosing what we ought
to it's when a person in some way not
necessarily all the way but some way
knows the good knows what the right
thing is and chooses something else
instead chooses the bad or the opposite
knows that something is bad and that
they shouldn't do it and yet they do it
anyway so where do I fall definitely
Aristotelian Aristotle thinks that we do
in fact experience across 'ya and it's
not just you know a lack of knowledge
about stuff people make dumb decisions
all the time
knowing that they're dumb people do in
fact choose the bad there's usually some
motivational process going on in the
background that we have to we have to
think about but I you know I'm I'm
totally on Aristotle's side on that one
let's see to do what can we go out on
with with one minute left see if we can
find a really nice thing to go out on to
do to do to do a lot of questions down
here and a lot of things also being
censored by YouTube as well let's see
here all right let me scroll up a little
bit
oh here's a good one to go out on so
it's about Leo Strauss and esotericism
how do I value Strout Leo Strauss his
ideas on esotericism so esotericism for
Strauss has to do with philosophical
texts and he says that various thinkers
said you know X but they really didn't
mean that there's really like a hidden
doctrine there's the exoteric
and then there's the esoteric and why
were they why were they doing that well
partly because you can't like put all
your ideas out there to begin with
because you might be like censored or
things like that but also to make the
reader have to work and okay so maybe
there's that let's consider that in the
abstract could that be the case sure
that could be the case should we think
that that's the case unless somebody
actually in my view unless somebody
actually comes out and says something
about their you know their esoteric
texts or doctrines or something like
that I'm pretty skeptical and the the
Strauss Ian's were an interesting Bunch
you know but a bunch that I don't agree
with a lot of stuff they will read into
classic texts and you know when I say
classic I'd mean ancient medieval modern
all sorts of stuff and they'll say well
this is what what you know this is what
Hobbes really saying or this is what you
know the Citadis or or this is what
so-and-so is really really about and a
lot of the time I'm not persuaded by by
their their points of view and I've
known quite a few Strauss students they
were kind of a for some reason I
encountered quite a few of them in the
circles that I I moved in in graduate
school and then you know for like maybe
the ten years after that but I just
don't I just don't buy it I think that
we should like look at what the text
actually says and unless there's some
good reason to think that there's
something underneath it that's more us
importing our own desire to find
something in there
and generally when people have some sort
of esoteric doctrine that's not really
based in a better reading of the texts
that's attentive to the texts it's I
think it's often for psychological
reasons people like to feel like they're
in the know they like to feel like
they're special like they've got they've
got a possession that nobody else has
and it strikes me as kind of a a
one-upsmanship that that I don't really
like so
alright that's that's probably enough
for today I got to go eat lunch and get
on with my my work and probably have to
walk this dog that you heard barking
before too long as well thanks for all
of your questions obviously I didn't get
to all of them but did as many as a them
as I could so I will see you the next
time around and I'll probably be doing
another dr. Sadler philosophy pop up
sometime this coming week